[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui boulevard voltaire au
numéro 118 à paris pour présenter une
toute nouvelle boutique une toute
nouvelle boutique qui a des produits
100% dédié shiori alors c'est pas une
boutique shiori s'est pas mis store
c'est un indépendant qui fait venir soit
les produits de chine soit directement
avec des fournisseurs européens
la boutique ceo astor et ici c'est tout
beau tout neuf ça résonne encore la déco
est très sympa qui vous montrera pas en
faire un peu le tour de la boutique vous
allez voir ça c'est impressionnant parce
que il ya plein de produits xiaomi qu'on
n'a pas encore tout de suite dans
l'écosystème français et européen qui
devra arriver je pense d'ici très peu de
temps
y'a pas chemin de choses ce que je
propose c'est de faire un tour de la
boutique
eh bien qu'aujourd'hui un peu plus
[Musique]
bon ce qui est cool dans cette boutique
déjà c'est la profondeur de gamme parce
qu'il ya plein de produits que vous avez
ici
typiquement vous allez par trouver
ailleurs en physique en france des
écouteurs d'autres écouteurs encore des
écouteurs des écouteurs à réduction de
bruit des écouteurs encore et toujours
une oreillette des écouteurs pour le
sport des écouteurs des écouteurs des
écouteurs en gros il ya beaucoup des
bouteurs brosse à dents brosse à dents
électrique parapluie enceinte connecter
les membres connectés america et le
stratos l'apeis et les modèles à niveau
3 nib en deux une bouilloire en baisse
personnes connectées un aspirateur une
chine pour cent leur il enfin vidéo
injecteurs une multiprise typiquement je
suis pas sûr que cette brosse à dents là
on puisse se retrouve alors là je vous
parle de brosses à dents c'était un
exemple un peu pourri parce que c'est
vous et pas forcément aller dans une
boutique qui vend des produits chez lui
pour avoir une brosse à dents quoique la
bourse 100 électrique de chez tommy
marche extrêmement bien mais il ya plein
de produits qui sont présents et
d'autres qui vont arriver qui viennent
directement de chine donc poulpe a
trouvé pour l'instant ailleurs en
physique dans notre stock en france une
caméra de surveillance à 360
cicas elle fit une box android des
ensembles collecter une autre enceinte
connecter une veilleuse avec détecteur
mouvement ils ont tous le connecter le
times
mini est bien évidemment la célèbre
trottinette électrique
il ya même un sapin de noël mais
celui-là il est pas vain on a eu notre
connectés qui a un effet un peu bougies
et bien évidemment des smartphones réuni
6 a réuni 6 reyniès de renmin 5 juillet
de like me à 2 me guilde s&p 2008 et en
os mais ici le pogo fin des fins des
bagages ici et ici on a aussi un coussin
pour tous vos voyages et bien évidemment
les fameux sacs marqués mais est ce
assez intéressant et en plus ce deuxième
point qui est intéressant c'est des prix
qui sont très compétitifs donc si vous
voulez acheter des produits chimiques
très bien placé vous pouvez venir taper
à la porte dans cette boutique est une
boutique en plus qui est d'ici quelques
jours va avoir un site en ligne
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant donc
pour tous ceux qui sont des amoureux de
la marque bien vous allez pouvoir
trouver des produits non dispo pour
l'instant dans le e-commerce en france
pas besoin et les fait revenir par des
importateurs que beaucoup connaissent
vous et pouvoir les acheter directement
chez les commerçants en ligne donc ça
c'est vraiment un bon plan est important
je voulais partager avec vous parce que
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant on voit
que chomis une boîte qui est énorme qui
a énormément de produits et même des
produits que je connaissais pratiquement
la bagagerie
c'est un truc que je connaissais pas
j'ai découvert il ya pa très très très
longtemps
autre point intéressant par rapport à
d'autres produits d'importateurs c'est
que là la boutique s'occupe directement
de son sav
donc s'il ya un problème vous n'avez pas
besoin de faire appel à un sav à l'autre
bout du monde
vous l'avez directement ici ça c'est
aussi un point très intéressant à noter
que le savez est assurée par la boutique
et non pas par chez nous ce sont
vraiment deux entités complètement
différente
typiquement les mondes connectés damas
fit voulais retrouver ici directement
pas besoin de passer par un importateur
ce qui était le cas jusqu'à présent
vous avez la stratos 2 j'ai pu testé il
ya quelques mois elle a dû arriver de
chine parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
disponibles ici donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant d'autant plus que ce
sont des produits qui sont bien placées
en termes de prix des objets connectés
un petit peu insolite on a aussi le
robot troc qui va venir nettoyer votre
maison fond en comble enfin ça on en
parlera que c'est un produit qu'on va
tester également d'ici quelques temps il
y aura plein d'autres produits à venir
et c'est surtout un concept de boutique
qui devrait faire des petits rien à voir
d'autres alors pour les parisiens
pourrait effectivement venir ici
boulevard voltaire pour les non
parisiens
ayez le site web pour faire vos achats
en ligne en tout cas aller voir et
comparer c'est vraiment très intéressant
donc je voulais partager ce bon plan
avec vous est utile aussi pour vous
dénicher les bons plans pour vous
trouver les bonnes astuces les bonnes
adresses donc ça c'est plutôt cool dites
moi ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous vous aimez beaucoup les produits
schumi je vois chaque fois il ya
beaucoup d'engouement c'est les produits
qui pèse après c'est vrai que les
produits sont extrêmement sympa très
bien fait et surtout à des tarifs
il perd hyper hyper compétitif donc vous
marier tout ça en commentaire parce que
vous en pensez les parisiens est ce que
vous connaissez cette boutique est ce
que vous pourriez venir la visite
et pour les autres qu'est ce que vous
pensez du shop en ligne vous ne marquez
tout ça on en parle ensemble et puis
rester qualité parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé de schumi il ya plein de produits
arriver d'ici quelques temps pas mal de
nouveautés et notamment début 2019 mais
jean-paul pas plus
merci à vous soyez sages à très bientôt
il s'en va ciao